après ben on vous invite ces semaines de
dévoilement de programmation dans
plusieurs théâtres du pays à montréal le
théâtre du nouveau monde ouvert le bal
le public nous le rend bien je sens je
sens que le de lancer une saison et
juste comme un miracle
anne marie cadieux sera la fiche dans
brasse une nouvelle pièce écrite par
michel marc bouchard durant la pandémie
je pense qu'on va en besoin de
s'embrasser aura besoin d'un câlin après
tout cette école
le tnm espère pouvoir présenter les
spectacles devant 500 spectateurs dans
une salle qui peut en accueillir 800 et
contrairement à la saison dernière pas
question de présenter des pièces moins
ambitieuse on n'a pas du tout imaginé
une saison avec moi d'accord - des corps
mais au contraire on est dans le
foisonnement de notre expression
artistique et je trouvais ça important
de faire au trident à québec le
lancement aura lieu demain on a
tellement été dans la crainte que le on
est juste dans le bonheur de retrouver
la scène et les spectateurs des grandes
solutions m'engage 70 acteurs
tribution à 20 à 12 écrans spectacle et
puis si une quatrième vague on se
retrouve tu mais pour l'instant
on a gagné beaucoup de souplesse
et mercredi seront tour de 10 m de
lancer sa programmation
ils ont choisi de jouer de prudence
après manuel de la vie sauvage une
grosse production présentée à compter de
septembre on se tournera vers de plus
petits spectacles à l'automne avant de
revenir à des pièces de plus grande
envergure en 2022 on sentait la notion
de riscle d'une éventuelle vague et ben
on se parle mais on se disait que en
janvier idéalement une très forte
majorité de la population serait double
vacciner et aurait envie de voir des
shows à grand déploiement après une
dernière année sombre pour les théâtres
la lumière est de retour sur scène et
s'il a dit alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal